أنا على وشك ركوب إحدى العبارات الأخيرة التي
تسير بين
مدينتي ماكاو وهونغ كونغ شبه المستقلتين
وهذا لأن حكومة مدينة هونغ كونغ
قد أعلنت للتو أنها
ستعلق هذه الخدمة اعتبارًا من منتصف الليل
بالتوقيت المحلي يوم الاثنين وهي جزء
من الجهود المبذولة لمحاولة وقف انتشار
فيروس كورونا القاتل ، إنه أيضًا
قرار يتم اتخاذه ، لقد
مارست ضغوطًا سياسية محلية كبيرة
لأن النقابة التي تمثل العاملين في المجال الطبي
قد هددت بالإضراب
إذا كانت المعابر الحدودية بين هونغ
كونغ و  بقية الصين ليست
مغلقة الآن خدمة العبّارات هذه ، أعني
أنها وسيلة نقل رئيسية
بين ماكاو وهونغ كونغ ، عبر عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص بهذه الطريقة
كل شهر هناك أشخاص
يتنقلون من العمل بين هاتين
المستعمرتين الأوروبيتين السابقتين وهذا الآن هو
الوصول إلى التوقف ، إنه مثال على كيفية
عزل أجزاء مختلفة من الصين
عن بعضها البعض في محاولة
لوقف انتشار المرض  في الوقت الذي
يحدث فيه هذا ،
توقف الحكومات والخطوط الجوية أيضًا
رحلات الطيران والطائرات إلى أجزاء من الصين في
محاولة لمنع الفيروس التاجي
من الوصول إلى بلدان أخرى Shores
Ivan Watson CNN على عبارة ماكاو هونج كونج